こんにちははじめ雪をです世界一黒い液体
黒色目そうみなさんご存知でしょうか
世の中には塗料というものがあるんですよ
棟梁らモデルに塗ったり壁に塗ったりとか
ものを色に染めるとき塗料というものを
使うんですけどもその中でも最も黒いと
言われている伝説の塗料北ショップ無双と
いうものがあります僕も動画で使ったこと
あるですけれども黒すぎて
消えるんですよ黒すぎてその場からない
ような鍵みたいになっちゃうっていう黒色
瞑想でスライム作ったんだけど真っ黒に
なっちゃいましたねネットいて使用もいい
ましたここは僕の3軒の家大家さんが誰だ
と思いますか a ぽくてというわけで私
は持ってしまったんです部屋をどう使おう
僕の自由端ええええええ部屋を1部屋全部
黒色無双でマック間にしてもいいんです
んかー
軽いん
いうわけでお部屋が結構多い来て使って
ない部屋があるんですけどもこちらの部屋
ですね入ってみましょう実はまだ何も使っ
てないんだなんては鏡もありますねうん
市場に飛来非常に広い余計なんですけども
使い道が今のところまだ決まってなくて
今回私がしたいことが訪韓でますね高
パワーを今まで者だろ報告者で同企画の
整形中盤から動画と考えがちだった
ゲームを丸ごと黒色武装で黒くしてみたい
と思ってを超えいいなというわけでキュン
とこの部屋を世界繕い十両で真っ黒にして
みたいと思いますどうなってしまうん
でしょもうそれ部屋と呼べるのかこんな皆
さん持ってる黒じゃないんですよこういう
風土くると思うんですか鍵ができるでしょ
模様という指輪
これ黒くないんですよこれで足りなさ知ら
ないと思いで黒くないんですどうだから
多分皆さんが想像3ずに真っ暗で違い繕い
とるねこの部屋はバックルするとたぶんを
空間と把握できない一見みたいな空間に
なると僕は予想しているので今日は実際に
それをやってみたいと思いますでは4校
すげー
war 今ん
上部ような黒色の操作されているため
だろうとし次行ってますのであのせます
こんなちっちゃくて2500円ですよね高
いって言われ捕手で剃ってもらった通り
タックス
てきたんですけどもケアを全部ウェルの
なーぐらいかかりませんです
いうことで前と黒色武装でするとても
100万を超えちゃうので正解スクール目
の初球になります黒色ルートこちら
たくさんあるんですけども狙える馬コの
ブロでカバーしていない熟語異空間を作っ
ていきたいとおもいます酷暑セットこう
いうのってちゃってそんな黒田というと腱
反射したんですよ
うわぁ
母
r封蝋
ショベルそう言うと告訴お部屋をナックル
していただきたいと思いますよ財団
[音楽]
beitr e b
というに前に世代作る true 出てき
た正解軸をいや完成しました
この中ですねありがとうございます乗車3
階2時間ぐらいかけてずれていただきまし
たどうなんですかねえってからカメラって
カメラって自動で暗いものにあっちゃうん
でちょっと設定書いてこんなもんだと思い
ます
入ってる場所入っています
ame
ああああああちょっと払う
これ
5しっかりついているんですよ一応これ
消費ついてます数
ブーブ
惚れいいですもう1校ここから先が異空間
すぎる閉めます
みなさんちょっと考えてますが大丈夫です
かねえか閉鎖空間でちょず込められた人
って今俺宇宙空間に閉じ込められた人々に
なってる数4重くっ部屋ですよ皆さん
ちょっと買って何の道路わからんもうわけ
でしょ彼は触れて来た少年ついてるんです
よちゃんとと杖てるのにいやが何も見え
ない
じゃっ品ですこれすごいな話で
ではちょっと紹介していこうと思います
これちょドアですねドア
ことはです本当なんですよ
マーナ近くに行ったらなんとなくわかるが
これたまたまがなんとなくわかった持って
これからいうかは知りました
足が浮いてるみたいなのよこれ部屋の全体
のですね
壁を数あってここお部屋の角になりますせ
効果でつづっ
徹底なんですねー
何だろう動画施工士外で訂正するの待って
いる状態
あっちょっと待ってい
メンって待ってください
ずっといたら頭おかしくなりぞこれ相手で
市街地黒い塗料ででした変なんですけど私
の木の葉学園のゲーム管理にこの絵に
こんな黒い空間があると応募はないと思う
んですよ野球人到着したんですけれども
早速目隠しして世界の竹置いたり入れて波
の力で製作がと自分の絵だと思っ
これと思います
ん
ちょっとこの中全くを待って待って待っ
てるねーーつぶってですねっ
入ってるはい
me
[音楽]
目を挙げてくださいパターン
ない方
ん
怖い
選びくるしても
boo
tan
by さん
この部屋
性が1黒い塗料で塗りずルースしまいまし
た素案は
くらいや
くらいズってくるいいんですよ確かに僕小
デブ想定してますあのもう真っ黒です眠
食べます
あーやばいんだよ
a 様もするのはくださいはーいはい時で
感じ23人は無事この日を見せられたので
ここから後輩が2人うちに遊びにきます
俺実施俺チェンは黒色別で真っ黒になって
この辺たらバカだと多分9分かられると
思うちょっと1回税申告書分袖手口黒い
人間になってみたいと思います
goo
ん
[音楽]
どう今ですねそう腕と腕とか大竹残して
もらって後黒色味噌で真っ黒になりますか
もうねぇないでしょこれはまだちょっと
乾いてないんですけれどもこれ乾くと本当
に真っ黒なるっぽいです独自ずに全部行き
たいと思います相手を入れる次世界一黒い
鳥を税収になりましたーーー
見えません皆さんこんなほど
方とか光当たると型照明でなんとなく形と
か分かりますね
んだろ
[音楽]
有効
パパ
きっと的なせる
ドア側に立つと結構半期分かるという感じ
ですよ
今からも弛んで俺に気づくことができるの
かどうかを実験したいと思いますかなり
暗いので分からないと思っんじゃああああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
食べ
プレイよう勧めるよ入った
おっ
ねえよっ
えっ
ん
このようなん
ワンワンワンワンワンワンワンa
ん
うわあああああああああああああんですよ
[音楽]
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
ん
えへっ
敗退
4日ああ
はい
なにこれはいいよ腐れ動けそうですまず
でよっ
ああああああ
maroon
ん
ただの黒いへ
黒いん
ワンワンワンワンワンワン白いフケくれよ
と思っ
なねー
ん
ああああああうん
駄文
何いいクロスもっ
yeahぺー
本当になるん
だよねー
ん
ゆっこらしょ
すごいなのっ
うわぁ
dj
あのっ
blr
[音楽]
あの2
えっ
わー
[拍手]
それは ir game さんどうでした
がいやーもう何も見えない番して心
て今度はの出現率低いからですね入った
ようですけどねもしれねぇ
言えば確かに